je vais maintenant vous parler d'une
autre conséquence qui pourrait se
produire dans l'océan mondial qui est la
modification de la circulation à grande
échelle qui assure un brassage de
l'ensemble de l'eau de l'ensemble des
bassins océaniques mondiaux vous avez
sur ce schéma duo un une représentation
stylisée de ce qui se passe dans l'océan
mondial sous l'effet des alizés et de la
rotation de la terre enfin comme les
alizés sont eux mêmes fruits de la
rotation de la terre on pourrait presque
dire sous l'effet de la rotation de la
terre les alizés comme vous le savez
sont des vents qui soufflent toujours
dans la même direction aux tropiques et
à l'équateur et ils vont donc avoir pour
effet de mettre en mouvement l'autre
surface c'est bon les chewing gum sont
distribués et numéro de téléphone donné
on peut avancer
ça va mettre en mouvement l'autre
surface des stands reste au niveau des
tropiques et à cause de monsieur
coriolis
c'est ce mouvement global de mouvements
des stands reste de l'autre surface au
niveau des tropiques va avoir pour
conséquence d'engendrer une boucle de
remontée de l'eau le long de la façade
atlantique et vous allez avoir près du
groenland un processus très particulier
de plongée des eaux qui va permettre à
dire une communication entre étages et
l'apparition d'une circulation en sens
inverse qui va recycler l'eau de surface
dans l'autre sens jusqu'au moment où
elles remontent à la surface dans le
milieu du pacifique
si vous faites une coupe de la
circulation dans l'océan atlantique
en gros vous avez une circulation de
surface d'eau chaude qui va du de
l'équateur vers le pôle nord et vous
avez une circulation d'eau froide qui
revient en sens inverse
dans les profondeurs pour que ce système
marche il faut bien évidemment que vous
ayez une forme d'ascenseur près du
groenland qui en l'occurrence fait
descendre l'eau et cet ascenseur
il est dû à une différence de salinité
et de température entre l'autre surface
et l'eau qui se trouve en dessous alors
plus exactement ça marche de la manière
suivante quand vous avez le qui est
transporté par la berri dans
l'atlantique dans le gulf stream c'est
parti vers le groenland
d'une part le a tendance à se refroidir
on va vers le pôle
et ça ça la rend plus dense et d'autre
part vous avez de l'eau douce qui
s'évapore et qui va aller précipiter
sous l'effet des alizés sur le pacifique
la vapeur d'eau s'échappe de la surface
les vents transporte cette eau vers
l'amérique centrale et vers le pacifique
et le précipite à cet endroit là et donc
comme l'eau douce n'est plus dans
l'océan mais que le sel lui y est
toujours
vous allez augmenter la salinité de
l'eau de surface
cette eau de plus en plus froide de plus
en plus salée à risques près du
groenland auquel est plus en plus dense
et au moment où la bâtisse va se former
pendant l'hiver
la banquise et de l'eau salée gelé mais
de l'eau salée moi je les que le maire
ait de l'eau au pardon moins salée que
l'eau de mer dont elle est issue
et la différence va être expulsé dans le
maire qui ne gèle pas donc en gros vous
avez une espèce de petit séparation deux
phases
vous prenez de l'eau salée elle gèle
vous allez retrouver une partie du sel
dans la banquise et une autre partie du
sel va être expulsé sous forme de saumur
dans l'eau qui n'a pas gelé ce qui veut
dire que l'autre surface va se retrouver
puisque c'est l'hiver particulièrement
froides puisque la reçu de la saumure
particulièrement salée et elle est
tellement grosse qu'elle va plonger et
c'est cette plongée de l'eau l'hiver qui
est un phénomène extrêmement puissant
puisque ça concerne millions de mètres
cubes à la seconde qui va engendrer
cette communication entre l'océan de
surface et l'océan intermédiaires et
profond mais ce faisant cette plongée
des eaux va avoir exactement le même
effet que l'on qui s'écoule de votre
baignoire
ça va attirer l'eau de surface qui se
trouve à proximité
donc ça fait une espèce de pompes
aspirantes
qui va attirer le gulf stream très au
nord si vous n'aviez pas cette pompe
aspirante vous aviez toujours les alizés
toujours cette mise en mouvement de
l'autre surface mais vous auriez un
courant qui bouclerait dans l'atlantique
beaucoup plus bas tout en restant en
surface l'eau ne montraient pas autant
au nord et elle ne plongerait pas vers
les profondeurs
il se trouve que cet ascenseur d'un
genre particulier
il a été arrêté un certain nombre de
fois au cours de la dernière ère
glaciaire et il a été arrêté par des
débâcles massive de la grande calotte
glaciaire qui se trouvait sur le canada
et qu'on appelait la calotte du
laurentides à cette calotte était
constituée d'eau douce au moment où on a
eu ces grande débâcle glaciaire
les icebergs qui se sont retrouvés dans
l'océan en fondant au amené énormément
d'eau douce à la surface de l'océan
l'eau douce est moins dense que l'eau
salée
donc cet ascenseur particulier près de
grenoble s'est arrêtée parce que l'autre
surface n'était plus assez dense pour
entretenir ce mouvement de plongée à ce
moment là vous avez eu une modification
rapide du climat surtout l'honneur de
l'atlantique nord ainsi que sur la
façade atlantique de l'europe où les
études qui ont été faites sur les
pollens recueillis à cette époque montre
que la végétation s'est très rapidement
transformé et de manière extrêmement
importante en l'espace de quelques
décennies on va dire cinquante ans plus
ou moins quelque chose avec
vraisemblablement des précipitations qui
ont chuté de plusieurs dizaines de
pourcents au moins sur la façade la plus
océanique de l'europe
vous avez eu dans le même temps une
baisse de la température d'environ cinq
degrés sur le nord de l'atlantique nord
alors pourquoi est-ce que vous avez vu
tous ces changements parce que le gulf
stream exportent vers les platitudes la
chaleur qui a été reçue du soleil aux
tropiques c'est un exportateur de
chaleur
le gulfstream l'exportateur la
mondialisation de la chaleur a démarré
bien avant celle des textiles chinois
donc le climat de l'europe de l'ouest
bénéficie d'un apport d'énergie sous
forme de l'insolation reçu d'autres en
pick qui est restituée
l'énergie restituée au niveau des
moyennes latitudes et des hautes
latitudes par le transport océanique et
atmosphérique qui en assurent le
couvercle avec son effet de serre quand
cet ascenseur d'un genre particulier
près du groenland
quand cette circulation entre le seeland
surface et l'océan profond s'arrête
eh bien vous avez des répercussions
climatiques extrêmement rapide sur
l'ensemble de l'atlantique nord c'est
très bien documenté par un certain
nombre de marqueurs qui ont été étudiées
par les physiciens
ici vous avez les épisodes qui
correspondent à ces débâcles de la syrie
après les événements de laâyoune riche h
quelque chose ici et qui correspondent à
plusieurs souhaiterait événements qui
sont concomitants d'abord vous allez
augmenter dans le fond de l'océan ce
qu'on appelle des sédiments détritiques
glaciaire alors le sédiment détritiques
glace erreur c'est détritiques ces
détritus ce pas comme dans la zizanie
c'est à dire c'est des petits bouts de
tony qui sont collés sous les icebergs
et qui sont le résultat du frottement de
la calotte sur le socle rocheux sur
lequel elle est portée donc quand les
icebergs partent à leur bilan les petits
gravillons qui sont collés sous leurs
pieds qui sont le résultat du frottement
de la calotte sur le socle rocheux
ces sédiments des critiques glaciaire
dans les carottes ce que vous prélevez
dans les fonds océaniques
vous allez retrouver des quantité
beaucoup plus importante pis les moments
où vous avez
ces débâcles ce qui est bien la marque
du fait qu' il ya eu des icebergs qui
soient baladés un peu partout au même
moment vous constaté une diminution
forte de la quantité d'oxygène que vous
avez dans les seins océanique en
analysant la teneur isotopique en
carbone 13 des coquilles des petits
micro organismes qui vont vivre dans les
fonds marins
donc vous avez des petits micro
organismes qui vivent dans les fonds
marins qui font des coquilles en
calcaire donc dans lequel vous avez du
carbone une fois killers assez
différentes
et quand vous regardez le rapport
isotopique ses traits sur ces 12 dans
les coquilles de ces petites bestioles
et bien vous constatez que et qui sont
la marque de la quantité d'oxygène que
vous allez y trouver eh bien vous
constatez que vous avez des variations
rapides moment juste où vous avez les
algues vertes qui sont baladés donc des
sédiments partout et vous avez la
température qui a ce moment la baisse de
manière significative et s'avoue le
déduisez de là aussi de la préformation
d'une molécule très particulière qui
s'appelle les roues d'une famille de
molécules qui s'appelle les halles qui
donne qui ont une conformation qui
changent en fonction exacte e mans une
proportion de molécules configurer d'une
certaine manière qui change quand la
température varie donc là c'est plus un
rapport isotopique c'est autre chose
dans l'analyse que vous pouvez faire
donc là c'est pareil
vous prenez les coquilles des organismes
qui ont vécu en surface vous regardez
vous les extrayez les carottes que vous
allez faire dans les fonds marins et au
moment où vous avez à la fois moins
d'oxygène dans les fonds et plus de ses
traces de passage on va dire des
icebergs et bien vous avez un marqueur
dans ces coquilles qui vous indiquent
que la température de surface a baissé
et enfin à ce moment là vous savez aussi
que la température au niveau du
groenland a varié de manière très
significative ça peut être 15 ou 20
degrés et ça vous allez le tracé avec le
rapport isotopique de l'oxygène 18 et du
deutérium dans la glace qui là aussi est
un marqueur de la température parce
qu'en gros là proportion d'isotopes
lourd de l'oxygène et de l'hydrogène
augmente dans la glace quand la
température planétaire augmente
et quand la température au dessus du
groenland augmente donc avec ces divers
marqueur vous avez la possibilité de
caractériser des époques
on pouvait y simultanément la
température a chuté fortement les
icebergs se mettent à se balader partout
et moins d'oxygène dans les fonds marins
et bien ça c'est quelque chose qui
s'explique assez naturellement si vous
imaginez que les icebergs en mettant de
l'eau douce partout ont cassé
l'ascenseur qui permet à l'eau
océaniques de surface chargé en oxygène
de descendre dans les fonds et donc vous
avez une ventilation en oxygène dans les
fonds marins qui a baissé
donc l'idée que cette circulation qu'on
appelle la circulation thermohaline
thermo parce que ça ça fait référence à
la température
aline parce que ça fait référence à chez
pas quoi je me demande si c'est pas de
sel
mais j'en suis pas sûr ce
au moment où cette circulation se grippe
ce bloc est bien vous avez des
modifications très simple et très
marquée de l'est du système climatique
ouest européen alors la question c'est
bien évidemment est ce qu'à l'avenir on
risque la même chose alors pourquoi est
ce que cette question est légitime parce
que à l'avenir vous allez avoir deux ou
trois processus qui vont concourir à une
diminution de la densité de l'autre
surface près du groenland le premier
processus c'est que vous avez vu tout
peur qu'on allait augmenter les
précipitations près du pôle nord
et donc on va amener par l'espace par le
poster plus exactement une quantité
croissante d'eau douce qu'il a tombé sur
la surface et qui va donc divisé la
salinité de l'eau de surface
le deuxième processus qui pourrait
éventuellement concourir à cette
modification
c'est que vous allez avoir une élévation
de la température de l'eau partout y
compris le qui se trouve près du
groenland
donc ça ça va aussi en diminuer la
densité et enfin le troisième processus
et vous allez handicapés la formation de
la banquise comme je l ai dit tout à
l'heure
donc vous allez diminuer l'apport de
celles que vous avez normalement en
hiver et qui permet à l'autre surface de
devenir particulièrement dense en plus
protégé du soleil par la banquise donc
particulièrement froide et de plongée
donc là vous avez trop processus qui
vont concourir tous les trois à ce que
la plongée d eux deviennent plus très
plus difficile qu'avant et la question
c'est bien évidemment est ce que l'on
est oui ou non
près du seuil où le processus s'arrête
brusquement parce que vous êtes dans un
processus à effets de seuil
un moment kraft c'est la dernière marche
et vous passez partie la falaise voilà
c'est exactement pareil
un moment vous franchissez un seuil et
le truc s'arrête brutalement en une
dizaine d'années
et bien la réponse est probablement pas
mais il va quand même y avoir un
ralentissement de la circulation dans
l'atlantique dans le siècle qui vient
vous avez ici la circulation dans
l'atlantique en question mesuré en
pertes de rup le sphère groupe c 1
million de mètres cubes à la seconde
donc ça fait beaucoup plus mal comme si
verte qui est aussi une unité qui se
symbolise par sv et vous verrez que
cette circulation nord-atlantique qui
stable jusque 1970 elle commence dans
les simulations abc aux alentours des
années 1970 c'est là j'ai pas le temps
de vous montrer les résultats mais il ya
un certain nombre d'analystes fait
aujourd'hui qui pose la question qui
clairement pose la question de savoir si
c'est pas déjà un ralentissement qui a
commencé mais il ya durée de recul qui
est pas suffisante pour pouvoir trancher
et quand je regardais la médiane des
inhalations pour le siècle qui vient
vous vous rendez compte que avec une
large part d'erreur c'est à dire que la
simulation la plus optimiste voit pas de
changement est la plus pessimiste nous
amène aux deux tiers de la rai puisque à
-25 on est totalement arrêtée
et bien l'ensemble des simulations
convergent plutôt dans l'idée que ça va
s'affaiblir à l'avenir et ceci explique
cela
c'est à dire que c'est cet
affaiblissement à l'avenir qui va
ralentir le transport de chaleur vers le
groenland et qui nous explique pourquoi
dans les graphiques que je vous ai
montré tout à l'heure le sud du
groenland était la partie de la planète
qui allait le moins se réchauffer c'est
que le réchauffement directs induits par
l'augmentation de l'effet de serre est
contrebalancé par le déficit en énergie
importées a mené par le gulf stream qui
lui va avoir plutôt tendance à
s'affaiblir et le résultat net à
s'éteindre est particulier c'est que ça
ne va pas beaucoup chauffé voilà c'est
ça c'est ça l'idée alors maintenant
encore une fois est-ce que un jour on
court le risque que ça s'arrête
brusquement à l'échelle du siècle
aujourd'hui la réponse des physiciens
sais c'est peu probable ils sont jamais
capable de dire c'est totalement
impossible mais il considère que c'est
peu probable
à l'échelle de quelques siècles ça
commence à devenir un risque sérieux
sans que qui que ce soit ne puisse dire
à quoi ressemble le système
après le franchissement de ce seuil
parce que les dernières fois que ce
genre de processus s'est passé on était
en verre glaciaire dont géographie la
planète est pas exactement celles qu'on
peut constater aujourd'hui
par ailleurs il y avait pas 7 milliards
de sédentaires mais quelques millions de
nomade donc la capacité d'aller se
mettre ailleurs était pas exactement la
même
et enfin les marques
les indicateurs qu'on peut avoir sur ce
qui s'est passé à cette époque sont
quand même un tout petit peu moins bien
- moins fournis que ce qu'on peut avoir
aujourd'hui donc est ce que ça pouvait
se passer
oui est ce que ça pourrait se passer
pendant siècle ce que programmables
qu'est ce qui se passe si ça se passe
personne n'en sait rien sauf que vous
pouvez quand même retenir une idée qui
est à mon avis qu'ils nous ont dit
presque tout l'accord énergétique eau
vive et des moyennes latitudes donc en
europe en europe de l'ouest et pour
moitié le fait du soleil et pour moitié
le fait de l'énergie importée des
tropiques par ce double tapis roulant
quel est le gulfstream et l'atmosphère
qui le surplombe
donc si on touche à l'un des deux termes
de manière importante
voyez dans un système dynamique dans
lequel vous toucher de manière violente
à la moitié de l'accord énergétique
selon toute vraisemblance il à se passer
des trucs bizarres
alors après quoi exactement
encore une fois si on attend de savoir
pour agir on aura des surprises amants
on pourra plus faire grand chose ici
vous avez la réponse
ou plus exactement une indications
quantitatives qui porte sur une question
qui est sur toutes les lèvres quand on
parle de ce genre de chose enfin du
changement climatique qui est est ce que
les ouragans vont augmenter et ont
augmenté je voulais dit la dernière fois
que l'augmentation des de l'intensité
des phénomènes extrêmes ou de leur
nombre ou de leur localisation était une
question qui se pose est naturellement
dès lors qu'on comprenait que le
changement climatique est quelque chose
qui va intensifier les processus
convectifs d'une manière générale à
partir du moment où vous intensifier les
processus convectifs d'une manière
générale bah ça paraît pas complètement
idiot de se dire que ça en particulier
ça pourrait avoir un effet sur les rangs
alors on va là comme ailleurs partir du
passé et on va commencer par regarder
les séries documenté sur l'intensité et
le nombre d'ouragans
c'est un exercice que vous ne pouvez pas
faire très loin dans le temps parce que
il ya 50 ans ou 60 ans ou 70 ans il y
avait des tas d'ouragans qui passaient
inaperçus
à partir du moment où vous n'avez pas de
satellite pour les regarder dans vous
n'avez pas de station météo au sol sur
lesquels il passe il n'y a pas de
navires sur lesquels il passe bas à
l'ouragan est passé personne n'en sait
rien donc le les mesures sur le nombre
précis d'ouragan lors leur étendue est
quelque chose qui n'est possible que
depuis l'avènement des satellites
d'observation et même pour mesurer avec
précision la vitesse du vent maximales
la vitesse du vent moyen etc
c'est quelque chose qui des possibles
que depuis un laps de temps relativement
bref donc savoir si les ouragans intense
augmente ou diminue et quelque chose qui
n'est pas pratique possible que depuis
l'avènement des satellites avant c'est
pas possible de répondre à la question
vous avez ici un graphique qui vous
donne l'évolution du nombre et aux
cyclones sur l'atlantique tropical entre
1966 et 2006 c'est à dire sur une
quarantaine d'années alors vous voyez
deux choses la première c'est que si on
regarde la courbe
ça semble augmenter mais dans les
dernières années
par contre si vous regardez le nombre en
valeur absolue et bien vous vous rendez
compte que ce qui semble être une
augmentation significative en fait c'est
passé par exemple d'une moyenne de
quelques joints à grands pas on va dire
5 à une moyenne de 7 sur une dizaine
d'années
ça c'est statistiquement non
significatif personne ne peut dire
aujourd'hui que de passer de 5 en
moyenne à 7 en moyenne sur un laps de
temps qui est de cinq à dix ans ça a une
signification statistique particulière
de savourer et puis ça peut pas tout
qu'on peut dire par contre il ya un
autre paramètre sur lequel il ya quelque
chose qui est beaucoup plus marquée qui
n'est pas le nombre mais qui est la
puissance moyenne
et vous savez que les ouragans ils ont
une échelle de notation aussi donc ils
sont notés de aaa ou plus exactement de
1 à 5 les ouragans les plus faibles et
en les ouvrant dès 14 heures des
catégories 1
et au fur et à mesure que la vitesse du
vent moyen et la vitesse du vent dans
les rafales au brandt est bien loin gand
est affublé
un numéro qui va croissant donc les
orages vents les plus violents sont les
ouragans de catégorie 4 et 5
et alors là par contre vous avez quelque
chose qui est statistiquement
significatifs qui que sur les 30
dernières années
vous voyez que dans l'atlantique nord le
nombre moyen d'ouragan de catégorie 4 et
5 par tranche de cinq ans est passé
d'environ 40 à environ 80 et ça c'est
quelque chose qui a une signification
statistique
andreu ce que dit ce graphique c'est que
sur les 30 dernières années
si on le conjugue avec le graphique
précédent
c'est difficile de savoir s'il ya
vraiment une augmentation tendancielle
significative du nombre d'ouragans
par contre quand un ouragan se forme il
est de plus en plus violents ça c'est
quelque chose qui a une signification
statistique
donc c'est c'est l'intensité sur
laquelle il y à un résultat
on peut considérer comme étant
significatif est absolument pas sur le
nombre ou du moins pour le moment et sur
le nombre
après vous avez ici autre chose alors je
parlais tout à l'heure de ce qu'on
appelait el niño avec son port dans qui
est la niña
el niño la niña sont les noms qu'on
donne communément à une grande
oscillations que vous allez trouver dans
le système climatique à l'échelle
planétaire et qui se caractérise
notamment par le fait que la partie la
plus chaude du pacifique se déplacent
d'est en ouest
donc quand vous êtes dans des conditions
normales l'eau chaude du pacifique elle
est plutôt à l'ouest l'eau chaude aller
plutôt à l'ouest à cause des alizés 1
les alizés pouces l'eau d'est en ouest
donc le qui est en surface eh bien elle
se balade des stands récent chauffants
et c'est quand elle arrive sur le bord
ouest du pacifique qu'elle est la plus
chaude l'eau qui est à l'est eh bien
elle vient de ce qu'on appelle en après
ling c'est à dire la résurgence de la
circulation profonde dont je vous ai
parlé tout à l'heure
celle-là même voilà j'ai tout celle là
même dont je vous ai parlé tout à
l'heure vous voyez la partie ascendante
de la circulation mondiale dans le
pacifique
et bien en fait c'est ça qui alimente le
la phrase bord est du pacifique en
régime normal donc ici vous avez une
plutôt froide qui remonte des
profondeurs riche en nutriments avec pas
le choix et les pêcheurs péruviens qui
sont contents et ici vous avez de
l'autre surface chaude avec des
précipitations importantes et des
caisses et des boissons qui permettent
aux agriculteurs indiens d'être content
et puis de temps en temps vous avez ce
qu'on appelle el niño
alors là celle inverse vous avez les
alizés qui s'inverse
la pastille d'eau chaude qui va se
coller à l'est plus dans choix des
pluies diluviennes qui sont plus à côté
de l'indonésie mais à côté du pire où ça
fait plein de glissements de terrain
et comme c'est une situation à l'échelle
planétaire vous avez également des
conséquences par exemple aux états unis
où vous avez en général des incendies
qui ne la font pas plaisir et qui ont
été particulièrement marqués lors du
dernier épisode fauga l'an dernier
exactement épisode animaux alors
maintenant vous regardez ici les
conditions et niño et les conditions de
la niña
donc quand vous êtes en la niña c'est
celle inverse saint denis vous êtes en
bleu et quand vous êtes en ligne où vous
êtes en rouge envoyé ça c'est une
oscillation donc ça se balade comme ça
et puis là apparemment il se met à y
avoir un peu plus de rouge que de bleu
donc apparemment el niño a plutôt
tendance à être un peu plus fréquent que
la niña question est ce que le
changement climatique va augmenter les
occurrences de la prade de phénomènes de
type el niño voit la balle à la réponse
est personne n'en sait rien c'est trop
tôt pour voir
par contre comme dans tous ses processus
sur lesquels je vous réponds c'est trop
tôt pour voir le jeu au one à une
conclusion définitive si c'était pas
celle qu'on espérait kever c'est trop
tard pour faire machine arrière pour en
vivre avec c'est le cas à cause de
l'inertie du système climatique de
toutes les conséquences auxquelles on
peut penser
autre exemple même si vous n'êtes pas
très vieux j'imagine que vous avez quand
même le souvenir de l'hiver 1999 en
france où il y a eu deux ouragans coup
sur coup
alors en france on appelait ça des
[ __ ] si vous allez chez nos amis
suisses sont nos amis allemands il
ils appellent ça des ouragans il les
appelle par leur nom ce qui s'appelait
lothar et martin en l'occurrence et tous
les autres ont un nom un prénom
avant c'était que des femmes qui
maintenant c'est mixte
l'idée est donc le tard et martin en
1999 et bien ça a correspondu
effectivement à une année où il ya eu
beaucoup d'épisodes tempétueux en france
mais pas plus que ce qu'il a pu y avoir
quelques années plus tôt et vous voyez
que depuis ces épisodes là le nombre de
tempêtes n'est pas en train de croître
de manière exponentielle
donc est ce que aujourd'hui il ya plus
d'épisodes tempétueux en france pas de
manière significative à la limite on
serait presque tenté de penser qu'il y
en a plutôt moins est ce que ça veut
dire qu'à l'avenir il y en aura moins en
moins ou de plus en plus août ses rangs
ben encore une fois comme je vous le
disais c'est trop tôt pour le savoir
là par contre on va revenir à une
conclusion qui est plutôt robuste dans
les conséquences du changement
climatique et qui en l'occurrence n'est
pas une conséquence du changement
climatique mais qui est une conséquence
du cycle du carbone
je vous ai montré je vous ai dit la
dernière fois qu'il y avait que deux
processus d'épuration du co2 de
l'atmosphère
enfin que deux principaux aux échelles
de temps qui nous intéresse aux échelle
de temps géologique c'est moins vrai le
premier c'était la reprise par la
photosynthèse et le deuxième c'était la
dissolution dans l'océan alors je vous
ferai tout à l'heure un beau diagramme
où je vous montrerai tous les termes et
des flèches qui vont dans tous les sens
à ce stade retenait une chose c'est que
plus vous mettez de co2 dans l'océan et
plus son ph baisse
vous savez que quand on met du co2 dans
l'eau ça a une certaine tendance à faire
h+ et h 03 - puis des tas de choses
derrière pour acheter aux 3 - et donc on
a sidi philo c'est pas un hasard que le
gaz carbonique aux époques anciennes ce
soit appelée l'acide carbonique dans les
vieux romans de jules verne c'est comme
ça qu'on l'appelait donc quand on met du
co2 dans l'air ça augmente sa pression
partielle et crack
il y en a une partie qui va passer dans
l'eau pour équilibrer les pressions
partiel essabah acidifier l'eau cette
courbe la halle à cette conclusion là
elle est très robuste veut dire le fait
que l'eau s'acidifient quand vous mettez
plus de co2
c'est une conclusion extrêmement robuste
après évidemment la question c'est
qu'est-ce qu'on perd en ph
vous avez ici un ensemble de cuivres qui
sont superposés et qui vous donne une
partie de la réponse
alors ce qu'on aime c'est ce qu'on
appelle des profils de ph en fonction de
la latitude
donc ça vous donne le plh moyen de
l'océan en fonction de la latitude
en partant de l'hémisphère sud et puis
exactement du pôle sud où comme vous le
savez il ya un océan en fait le sait on
commence plus tôt à 75 et vont aller
jusqu'au nord dans l'autre sens c'est
pareil avec l'évolution du ph
cette jeune grise représente la bande
dans laquelle se trouvait le ph de
l'océan mondial au moment
enfin avant le début de la civilisation
industrielle donc au moment qu'on
appelle pré industriels
on va dire 1750 donc en 1750 le ph par
exemple aux abords de l'antarctique est
autre 8,2 à 8,3 en valeur la plus
probable et puis comme ce truc là elle
reconstituée avec des simulations en
fait vous avez devant d'erreurs donc en
fait il était probablement n'importe où
atteint 8,8 25 et 8 35
il est n importe où entre 8,2 à 8,35
8,40 à ce moment là mais avec une balle
est la plus probable qui est est ce que
vous avez ici entièreté
aujourd'hui le profil de plage de
l'océan mondial qui est mesuré vous
l'avez avec sept clubs et noir
vous voyez donc le séance est déjà un
peu acidifier depuis l'époque
préindustrielle il ya déjà eu une baisse
de ph et la bonne du bas vous donne la
zone dans laquelle on se situera ou
situerait en 2100 en fonction de ce que
seront les investit les émissions de gaz
à effet de serre pardon d'ici à 2100 si
elle laisse dans un scénario de bah là
avec une stabilisation à 550 parties par
million de co2 en 2100 c'est à dire que
on
à peu de choses près dans le scénario
émission constante dont je vous parle
depuis le début est bien le scellant
mondiale perdra entre eux allez on va
dire aux alentours de 0 2 point de ph
si on est dans un scénario est donc on
utilise plein de charbon à ce moment on
se rapproche de la courbe endroit ingrat
que vous avez en bas ici ou là vous
perdez un dixième de point de ph
supplémentaires dans tous les cas de
figure l'océan va s'acidifier une partie
de cette acidification on ne sera que le
rattrapage du surplus de co2 on a déjà
mis dans l'air donc cela le coup est
parti
on ne changera plus et le supplément
qu'on aura en plus du coût qui est déjà
parti va dépendre de la quantité de co2
qu'on mettra encore dans l'air dans les
quelques décennies qui viennent
alors vous allez me dire un 7,9
c'est pas encore ça qui va nous empêcher
de baigner dans l'eau nous veiller dans
l'eau pardon ce qui est parfaitement
vrai par contre ça va diminuer la
disponibilité en ions carbonates et il
se trouve que ces ions carbone actes
sont absolument indispensables à une
large fraction de la vie marine
c'est à dire à tous les micro organismes
qui ont besoin de synthétiser du
calcaire et en particulier l'une des
formes de calcaire qui est le plus
sensible à la baisse du ph
est ce qu'on appelle l'aragonite et
c'est un des calcaires qui est utilisé
en particulier par le phytoplancton donc
veut être sensible à ce genre de
processus
tous les organismes qui ont besoin de
synthétiser des calcaires
alors vous en connaissez quelques-uns
savoir les homards à les huîtres n'y a
pas que ça
vous avez aussi les coraux vous avez le
phytoplancton vous avez tous les
mollusques qui ont une coquille même
certains êtres qui sont pas des
mollusques et qu'une coquille quand même
une carapace et même les tortues par
exemple et son besoin de synthétiser du
quelques heures et donc vous allez
trouver une foultitude d'être marin qui
vint globalement ne pas apprécier le
fait d'être dans une eau plus acide a là
aussi très difficile de caractériser le
seuil de résistance des écosystèmes à ce
genre de conditions d'ensemble à ce
genre de modifications pardon
ensemble de leurs conditions de vie pour
avoir une réponse à ce genre de
questions il faudrait d'une certaine
manière faire l'expérience suivante vous
prenez l'ensemble d'un écosystème marin
vous le mettez dans un immense aquarium
dans lequel vous acidifier
progressivement l'eau en augmentant la
concentration en co2 dissous et vous
regardez ce qui se passe au bout de 10
ans ou 20 ans ou de 50 ans ou d'un
siècle on n'a pas les moyens de faire ce
genre d'expérience donc là comme
ailleurs on saura ce que ça donne que
une fois que les résultats sont là on
peut imaginer encore une fois qu' un
certain nombre de bestioles qui vont pas
aimer mais une fois qu'on a dit ça on a
à peu près tout dit par ailleurs il faut
quand même se rappeler que la pression
de l'homme sur la vie marine n'a pas
attendu le changement climatique pour
être extrêmement élevé et retenez cette
idée par exemple exactement cet ordre de
grandeur que la biomasse dans
l'atlantique nord
donc le clos total de tout ce qui vit
dans l'atlantique nord a regretté divisé
par dix en un siècle sous la pression de
la pêche à peu près un facteur 10 donc
la quantité de poisson qui vit
aujourd'hui dans l'atlantique nord c'est
dix fois moins que ce qu'ils vivaient il
ya un siècle et il ya déjà des pêcheries
dans l'atlantique nord qui ont bel et
bien disparu notamment les morues sur
les bancs de terre-neuve où malgré les
moratoires qui ont été mis en place
quand on a commencé pensé que ça allait
vraiment tourné au vinaigre
les stocks se sont effondrés maintenant
il ya plus de morue évidemment une fille
de pêcheur il ya plus de poissons non
plus ce que je vous ai raconté sur le
cycle du carbone
je vais l'énergie et donc le fait que ça
passe dans l'océan en fait je vais
l'élargir sur ce diagramme qui va
essayer de vous donner une vue
d'ensemble de la manière dont ce cycle
est connecté au changement climatique
vous avez ici des chiffres associée à
des flèches en rouge et en noir qui se
interprète de la manière suivante
tous ces chiffres représentent des
milliards de tonnes de carbone lors vous
avez les chiffres au sein de flèches
ce sont des flux annuels par exemple 70
au milieu de cette flèche ça veut dire
70 milliards de tonnes de carbone qui
descendent de l'atmosphère vers l'océan
mais vous avez ces chiffres donnent
associés à des flèches
ça représente de stoke par exemple dans
l'atmosphère 597 ça veut dire 597
milliards de tonnes de carbone dans
l'atmosphère est ici vous avez par
exemple 37 mille milliards de tonnes de
carbone dans l'océan intermédiaires et
profond
les chiffres qui sont en noir représente
la description du système du cycle du
carbone avant le début de l'ère
industrielle
donc vous prenez une photo virtuel du
cycle du carbone en 1750 et vous n'avez
que les chiffres noirs
vous n'avez pas les chiffres en rouge
les chiffres en rouge c'est la
différence c'est le surplus ou le
déficit qui a été rajouté
depuis le début de l'ère industrielle
exemple le moment du début de l'ère
industrielle
vous aviez avons 600 milliards de tonnes
de carbone dans l'atmosphère
essentiellement sous forme de co2
aujourd'hui vous en avez 765 pleinement
où on était au début de l'ère
industrielle
vous aviez 70 milliards de tonnes de
carbone qui redescendait chaque année de
l'océan de la pression vers l'océan
aujourd'hui vous en avez 22e deux de
plus et c'est le aujourd'hui
s'interprète comme le milieu des années
90 parce que évidemment ces flux là ils
varient tous les ans ce graphique là il
va me servir à vous expliquer comment ça
se passait avant nous exactement avant
nos activités industrielles est ce qu'on
est en train d'y faire avant nous vous
avez un certain nombre d' échanges entre
l'atmosphère qui contient du carbone
sous forme de co2
et les autres compartiments de la
planète qui en contiennent sous des
formes diverses
les écosystèmes terrestres par exemple
en contiennent sous forme de matière
organique mais aussi du mus dans les
sols c'est à dire de matières organiques
en fin de match de matières qui a été
vivante et qui ne l'est plus et le séant
le contient essentiellement sous forme
non carbonatées bicarbonate et ça doit
extrêmement plus à la vie marine puisque
vous voyez que la vie marine ces 3
milliards de tonnes de carbone ridicule
devant les 2300 contenu par les
écosystèmes terrestres dont vous pouvez
zigouiller toutes les baleines ça ne
change strictement rien aux stocks de
carbone qui est contenu dans l'océan
jade est à double inconvénient mais pas
suivre donc
avant l'ère industrielle l'océan et
changent chaque année 70 milliards de
tonnes de carbone avec l'atmosphère
ces échanges sont essentiellement dues
aux variations de la température de
surface des masses 2 qui se déplace il
se trouve que la solubilité du co2 dans
l'eau est meilleur quand l'eau est
froide que quand l'eau est chaude
en d'autres termes pour vous refroidit
c'est de l'eau vous accroissez sa
solubilité en co2 et c'est bien
évidemment l' inverse quand l'eau se
réchauffe
vous avez vu tout à l'heure qu'il y
avait un vaste mouvement de brassage de
l'eau océanique à l'échelle mondiale
c'est à dire que l'eau qui est ici à un
moment va se retrouver dans un autre
moment et puis encore là trois siècles
plus tard
et puis encore là cinq siècles plus tard
et c'est en se déplaçant elle change de
température donc le qui est en train de
se refroidir
à un moment donné va pomper du co2 en
provenance de l'atmosphère ce soit
l'humilité augmente alors que mel qui
est en train de se réchauffer l vaart
rachez le co2 qu'elles n'arrivent plus
la dissoudre dans l'est prospère et qui
est bien évidemment le co2 qu'elle avait
pompé de l'atmosphère une semaine avant
un mois avant un siècle avant cinq
siècles avant donc les échanges de co2
entre l'atmosphère et l'océan de surface
sont essentiellement dues à des
variations de température des masses
d'eau océanique
en ce qui concerne les parties émergées
de la planète
donc là vous constatez par donc on finir
là-dessus que en ce qui concerne l'océan
les échanges ne doit strictement rien à
la vie
faute de moyens c'est juste une question
de thermodynamique
1 la solubilité est meilleur dans l'eau
froide que dans l'eau chaude
donc quand l'eau se refroidit ça descend
et quand l'eau se réchauffe savons pas
vie s'allonge la même manière en ce qui
concerne les écosystèmes terrestres là
c'est tout l'inversé
c'est essentiellement est quasiment
uniquement due à la vie le flux
descendant c'est la photosynthèse
donc vous avez les plantes qui
synthétise des glucides grâce à des
photons et au carbone contenue dans
l'atmosphère sous forme de co2 le flux
montant est celui de la respiration des
plantes et des animaux alors les plantes
respire
exactement comme nous donc en fait elle
mange par la peau ça c'est la
photosynthèse et une partie du carbone
qu'elles ont retiré de l'atmosphère elle
le remettent dans l'atmosphère en
respirant l'autre partie vient accroître
le tronc les feuilles et les racines etc
jusqu'au moment où elles mort et à ce
moment le produit de l'appelant morte
pour la plante mans et manger par des
microbes qui le même respire et ça ça
vous restitue du co2 à l'atmosphère donc
la respiration des macros organismes
comme nous et les zébus et des
micro-organismes virus champignons micro
ondes etc vous restitue du co2 à
l'atmosphère les micro organismes se
nourrissant général des restes des
macros organismes puisque vous savez que
vous finirez en poussière comme moi ces
flux naturels sont globalement à peu
près équilibré vous voyez 70 milliards
de tonnes échanger dans chaque sens en
ce qui concerne chaque année avec
l'océan et 120 milliards de tonnes
échanger dans chaque sens en ce qui
concerne les écosystèmes émerger et puis
là dessus arrive l'homme avec ses gros
sabots et alors l'homme il fait deux
choses la première c'est qu'il va
déstocker des combustibles fossiles qui
était auparavant situé sous terre et
qu'ils n'avaient pas l'intention d'en
sortir rapidement
il en serait sortie de toute façon à
cause du volcanisme parce qu'un jour ou
l'autre les réservoirs de pétrole ils
sont pris dans la tectonique des plaques
et ça finit par sortir mais ça a pris
beaucoup plus de temps
bon au milieu des années 90 les hommes
ont déstocké à peu près 250 milliards de
tonnes de carbone et l'ont mis dans
l'atmosphère sous forme de co2 ses
émissions annuelles mais émissions
annuelles de l'huma
était au milieu des années 90 sont de
6,5 milliards de tonnes par an et
aujourd'hui on est plutôt à cet ennemi
et puis les hommes ont également coupé
des forêts et comme je vous le disais
dans l'ombre d'une session précédente
ces forêts coupé c'est essentiellement
du bois qui va être brûlé pour ça finit
sous forme de co2 dans l'atmosphère
aussi à cause de la grande stabilité
chimique du co2 une fois dans
l'atmosphère le co2 n'est pas recyclé
rapidement et il ya eu un accroissement
de la quantité de co2 dans l'atmosphère
qui est d'environ 165 milliards de
tonnes depuis le début de la
civilisation industrielle
cet accroissement a déjà provoqué une
élévation de température
cette élévation de température s'est
communiqué à l'océan et cette élévation
de température globale de l'océan de
surface augmente le flux de co2 montant
puisque comme je voulais 10e flux
montant est lié aux masses d'eau qui se
réchauffe
dans le même temps l'augmentation de la
concentration en co2 dans l'atmosphère
que si j'augmente le stock
atmosphériques de co2 dans un volume
donné
j'augmente la concentration en co2 donc
l'augmentation de la concentration en
co2 dans l'atmosphère ou entre la
pression partielle de co2 dans
l'atmosphère
lui par contre dans d'accroître le flux
descendant puisque comme avant
l'atmosphère et l'océan vous recherchez
toutes choses égales par ailleurs à
équilibrer la pression partielle donc
s'il augmente la concentration de co2
dans l'atmosphère
j'augmente le flux descendant vers
l'océan
coup de bol pour le moment le flux
descendant est plus important que le
flux montants football parce que les
deux processus qui sont à l'origine du
flux montants et du flux descendant sont
pas les mêmes d'un côté élévation de
température de l'autre accroissement de
la pression partielle c'est pas la même
chose sauf que pour le moment il se
trouve que le flux descendant engendrés
par l'accroissement de la pression
partielle est plus important que le flux
montants engendrés par l'élévation de
température ce qui veut dire que sur les
sept et demi
enfin six et demi à l'époque plus à et
demi c'est à dire les milliards de
tonnes de carbone que l'homme mais dans
l'atmosphère
bah l'océan passe la balayette pour
deux corps au moment le second est un
puits mais c'est un puits c'est un
équilibre dynamique c'est pas un truc
est garanti pour l'éternité s'est appuyé
tout de suite et maintenant parce qu'il
se trouve que le résultat de flux qui ne
sont pas dus à la une cause et une
séquestration est bon l'océan en ce qui
concerne les écosystèmes terrestres
c'est pareil les deux flux ne vont pas
évoluer de la même manière dans un
premier temps quand vous augmenter un
peu la quantité de co2 dans l'atmosphère
et que vous augmentez un peu la
température planétaire
c'est globalement une excellente affaire
pour les plantes et du reste le sirop
arrhenius quand il avait fait ses
premiers calculs sur l'élévation de
température liés au changement
climatique
globalement les trouvais que c'était une
excellente chose parce que je vous
rappelle qu'en 1900 il n'y avait pas de
tracteur n'y avait pas d'engrais la
régularité et l'abondance des récoltes
étaient encore un vrai sujet la moitié
de la population ou pas loin vivaient de
l'agriculture
donc la place fautive d'avoir un peu
plus à manger pour les plantes dans
l'atmosphère et une saison de pouce qui
s'approche un peu surtout car à nu
c'était suédois donc la longueur de la
saison 2 pouces il savait ce que c'était
il trouvait que c'était globalement
plutôt une bonne idée 1
et pour peu qu'ils aient eu envie
d'aller prendre des bains il trouvait
que c'était une excellente idée donc a
réussi voyez une bonne nouvelle sauf
qu'il avait raison pour plusieurs os 5
ou plus pour plus d'un degré à +5 à mon
avis il avait tout à fait tort mais à +0
5 fois plus à ce qu'on constate
aujourd'hui
eh bien on a un effet d'accroissement de
la photosynthèse et donc vous allez
augmenter le flux de cendres mais dans
le même temps l'augmentation de la
température vous augmente la respiration
microbienne parce que ça vous augmente
la décomposition de tout ce qui est
matière phare végétaux mort 1
l'humus les résidus organiques de la vie
passée sont des composés de manière plus
rapide quand la température augmente
et puis quand elles augmentent
suffisamment vous commencez à voir
apparaître des incendies partout qui
constitue un flux de restitution du
carbone à l'atmosphère particulièrement
efficace donc la température augmente
encore plus vous allez accroître le flux
de restitution du carbone à l'atmosphère
à la fois à cause des incendies et à
cause de l'accélération encore de la
respiration microbienne et notamment de
la respiration microbienne qui prend
place dans les sols là vous avez lu
parce que les microbes qui sont présents
dans les sols
il y en a une partie qui mange le bus
6ème sens là il faut savon et il respire
donc il restitue à l'atmosphère sous
forme de co2 le carbone qui était
initialement contenues dans les débris
végétaux et animaux que vous avez dans
le bus passé un certain stade le puits
continental lui va commencer à
s'affaiblir
c'est la traduction de la disparition
des êtres d'une partie de la france dont
je faisais ce que je vous ai montré tout
à l'heure c'est à dire que passé un
certain stade les écosystèmes installé
et vont commencer à ne plus autant
prospéré qu' il ne prospérait avant et
donc le flux descendant lui il a
commencé à s'affaiblir donc vous verrez
que pour le moment le flux montant et le
flux descendant résultait on a pu
continental qui fait en gros deux
milliards et demi de tonnes de carbone
par an mais haddock un flux montants qui
s'intensifie et un flux descendant qui
s'affaiblit bien encombrant ou vous
renverser le signe du résultat c'est à
dire que eu lieu que les écosystèmes
terrestres soit 1 puis ça devient source
et à ce propos on peut s'arrêter de
conduire et de se chauffer le truc est
parti dans une boucle alors ça finira
par converger sauf que personne ne sait
où ce genre de processus pourrait se
mettre en oeuvre dans les décennies qui
viennent
je vais vous montrer après quelque chose
qui s'est passé enfin les résultats
d'une étude qui a été menée sur ce qui
s'est passé en europe l'été 2003 en
europe l'été 2003 on a déjà transformé
les écosystèmes terrestres depuis en
source
cette année là ils ont déjà craché
beaucoup plus de co2 qui n'en n'ont
absorbé c'est pareil en ce qui concerne
l'océan vous augmentez la températures
océaniques
vous allez augmenter le flux montants
qui croît avec la température
par contre passé un certain stade la
concentration atmosphérique en co2 va
s'arrêter de croître besoin elle peut
pas croître indéfiniment un donc elle va
s'arrêter de croître et à ce moment
l'équilibrage de pression partielle va
engendrer un plus qui va aller on
diminuant parce qu'une partie croissante
du co2 passant dans l'océan dans ma foi
il y en aura de moins en moins m pour
équilibrer les deux se ce que je suis en
train de vous dire c'est que le carbone
qui est aujourd'hui stockées par les
écosystèmes continentaux et stockées par
le cndd surface il est stocké dans des
endroits où il est des stocks câble à
l'échelle de quelques décennies ou de
quelques siècles pour retourner dans
l'atmosphère vous avez donc un système a
servi dans lequel plus de co2 peut
signifier plus chaud mais plus chaud
peut aussi signifier plus de co2 et du
reste plus chaud au signifiant plus de
co2 est très vraisemblablement ce qui
s'est passé au cours des temps
géologiques où la variation de
température de la planète
la température moyenne semblent avoir
précédé les variations du co2 dans
l'atmosphère et non pas l'avoir suivi
là on est dans un contexte dans lequel
la variation du co2 dans l'atmosphère va
précéder la variation de température et
bien lors de la dernière l'heure de la
déglaciation qui a pris place il ya deux
cent cinquante mille ans à était l'exact
inverse
c'est d'abord la variation de
température qui a eu lieu puis la
variation du co2 dans l'atmosphère est
la risée et le processus avec lequel on
explique ça c'est cette réponse de
l'océan qui fait que au moment où à
cause des forçage astronomiques pour
réchauffer le système climatique dans
son ensemble est bien quand l'océanic se
réchauffe suffisamment et fini par
cracher du co2 par mètre du co2 dans
l'atmosphère dont vous avez d'abord la
température puis le co2 il n'y a pas de
raison que ce processus se manifeste pas
à l'avenir donc encore une fois le seuil
de basculement en ce qui concerne les
écosystèmes terrestres
il est peut-être simplement quelques
décennies devant doute personne n'en
sait rien non plus là de manière très
précise et en ce qui concerne les océans
il pourrait commencer à se manifester de
manière significative dans quelques
siècles
l'augmentation complètement la
diminution du ph va également avoir une
incidence sur les flux de carbone entre
le co2 dissous dans l'eau de surface et
la vie marine et là aussi c'est très
difficile de savoir ce qui va se passer
si je prends le résultat net du cycle du
carbone que je viens de vous évoquez
donc là je vous ai montré
les flèches qui allaient dans un sens et
dans l'autre dont vous avez les
composantes du système maintenant on va
regarder le résultat net le résultat net
c'est que les émissions de co2 de
l'humanité tout agrégé donc
déforestation plus combustibles fossiles
plus la décarbonatation du calcaire pour
faire du ciment c'est ça que vous avez
dans votre émission dans votre émission
vous avez le fait que les cimentiers
près du calcaire donc caco3 et il sait
par ça en cae survivent et co2 qui met
dans l'atmosphère camper frère du ciment
vous avez obligatoirement besoin de
mettre du co2 dans l'atmosphère pour
casser votre molécule le carbonate de
calcium donc le sait ça l'est encore une
fois les autres émissions dont vous avez
des émissions de co2 qui sont passés
alors en carbone s'est passé de 4 à
quasiment 10 et en co2 s'est passé en
route 15 à quasiment 40 milliards de
tonnes en un peu moins de 50 ans comme
c'est indiqué la danse est même dans ce
même laps de temps
l'océan à absorber une partie des
émissions annuelles donc c'est en fait
c'est le résultat de ce que je vous ai
montré tout à l'heure et cette fraction
annuel est à peu près constante en
valeur absolue et la grange a légèrement
augmenté mais maintenant plus tellement
en valeur absolue ce qui veut dire qu'on
part relative à la tendance à baisser
donc le sait on aujourd'hui parce la
balayette d'aller un quart de nos
émissions
mais c'est une c'est une proportion qui
a tendance à baisser avec une très large
variabilité annuel une très large
variabilité annuel les écosystèmes
continentaux andreu aujourd'hui il passe
la balayette derrière à peu près 30% nos
émissions et cette très large
variabilité annuel est dû au fait que
vous avez là un résultat faible
on parle de 1 à 2 milliards de tonnes de
carbone sur des flux qui font 120 dans
chaque sens donc il suffit que d'une
année sur l'autre celui qui fait 120 il
passe à 118 est haute à 122 ou l'
inverse pour que vous ayez un résultat
qui est plutôt +4 ou plutôt moins 4 donc
c'est en entendant ce monde vous avez
les écosystèmes qui récupère une partie
du co2 qu'on met dans la
mais d'une année sur l'autre
ça peut varier de manière extrêmement
forte il n'y a rien d'anormal là dedans
alors maintenant vous savez comme moi
faire sans moins 33 25
ça veut dire que en gros à peu près la
moitié de nos émissions actuelles
s'accumulent dans l'atmosphère où elles
accroissent le stock atmosphérique ceci
explique cela
vous comprenez quand vous voyez ça que
il faut a minima pour que la quantité de
co2 s'arrête de croître dans
l'atmosphère que l'on divise les
émissions planétaires par deux c'est une
approximation au premier ordre
c'est une approximation au premier rang
d'abord pour des raisons d'intégrale
bornes et dont je vous ai parlé lors du
premier cours de toute façon un jour ça
sera pas bons par beaucoup plus que deux
ce que l'approvisionnement en
combustibles fossiles est infini et la
surface de forêt à défricher et en finit
encore une fois mes émissions de co2
d'origine humaine montant d'eur 0 à
l'infini donc un jour ça sera divisé par
deux et même par trois et même par 4 et
1 par dix le qu'est ce que veut dire le
met au premier rang il faut au moins
diviser sa part 2 et si on alloue de
manière équitable
à chaque humain de la planète des
émissions mondiales divisé par deux sa
donne en france le fameux facteur 4
mais ça on regardera ça un peu plus en
détail la prochaine fois je vous le
disais tout à l'heure que l'été 2003 a
été l'occasion de répéter grandeur
nature ce qui se passera peut-être d'ici
quelques décennies et que je ne vous
souhaite pas parce que encore une fois
si ça se met en route
c'est très difficile de savoir où ça
s'arrête voyez bien que si les
écosystèmes continentaux commence à être
suffisamment déstabilisés et à dépérir
suffisamment pour cracher du co2 au lieu
d'en absorber bailly crash du co2 qui
s'accumulent dans l'atmosphère le climat
se réchauffe encore plus les systèmes
sont encore plus près les écosystèmes
sont encore plus déstabilisé donc il
crache encore plus de co2 donc et c est
encore une fois ça finira par converger
et personne n'est capable de dire où
quand comment et quel est l'état de la
planète une fois que sera fini de
converger voilà un exemple de ce qui
s'est passé donc je vous dis en modèle
réduit
enfin un exemple de ce processus en
modèle réduit en europe l'été 2003 ce
graphique vous donne un rapport à la
normale donc d'habitude vous êtes en
situation normale
les écosystèmes absorbe une certaine
quantité de co2 via la photosynthèse et
en 2003 par tous est jeune ou rouges ou
roses c'est des endroits où la
photosynthèse à absorber moins de
carbone que d'habitude donc là vous
voyez par exemple là où vous êtes
rouge c'est que vous êtes andreu à 500
grammes de carbone par mètre carré en
moins qu'une année normale
vous vous absorbez quelques tonnes de
carbone à l'hectare vous avez donc sur
l'essentiel de l'europe et en
particulier sur les partis qui sont
plutôt montagneuse ua déstockage très
significatif de carbone parce que les
plantes ont quasiment pas photo
synthétiser alors que dans le même temps
les sols eux ils ont continué à émettre
à cause de la décomposition de l'humus
être éléments qui vous matérialise de
risque vous avez ici avec les anglais il
adore jouer au golf et au cricket
et pour ça il ya besoin de faire des
trous alors il ya des chercheurs c'est
devenu des spécialistes des troupes
donc ils ont mis cette expertise à
profit et il ya des chercheurs anglais
qui en 1978 ont fait 3000 trou en
angleterre et ils ont regardé quelle
était la quantité de carbone qu'il y
avait dans le sol au 3000 endroits où
ils ont fait des trous et puis comme 25
ans après il aimait toujours autant le
golf et de cricket
ils ont refait trois mille trous en 2003
et ils ont regardé la quantité de
carbone alors les trois mille trous de
2003 ils les ont fait juste à côté des
trois mille trous de 1978 sinon ce que
je vais vous raconter évidemment n'a pas
de signification
donc ils font de nouveau trois mille
trous au même endroit et il constate que
à peu près partout
la teneur en carbone des sols a baissé
donc là où il y avait du carbone il y en
a un peu moins et il constate que cette
baisse a été d'autant plus rapide en
pourcentage que le stock initial de
carbone étaient élevés ou es ce que vous
avez des stocks initiaux de carbone
élevée
dans les prairies et dans les forêts
alors ici si vous arrivez à voir les
parties blanches correspondent à des
forêts et vous avez également des
prairies qui correspondent au parti bleu
et là où ça a baissé le plus vite ces
banques essentiellement là elle vous
aviez de ferrer et des prairies c'est à
dire des sols non laguna et ça c'est
important parce que quand vous la
goréens sol vous exposer le bus à
l'oxygène de l'air donc vous pouvez
assez logiquement vous attendre à ce que
ce soit préférentiellement oxydé or il
se trouve que c'est en tout cas que ça
favorise la vie aérobie ben là c'est
exactement l'inversé qu'on observe c'est
là on ne sait pas labourer que le
carbone a été déstocker plus rapidement
et alors l'hypothèse qui vient en
premier dans l'esprit des chercheurs qui
ont trouvé ça il s'agit encore une fois
d'une hypothèse qui vient en premier il
s'agit pas de preuve à ce stade c'est
que c'est déjà un effet du relèvement
des températures qui a fait que les
petites bestioles dans le sol qui vivent
en consommant l'humus et bien elles se
sont régalés plus vite que les plantes
non approvisionné le sol en humus pour
rhj apport pour recharger le sol en
matière organique si vous couplez ça à
ça eh bien vous vous rendez compte que
en europe
on est peut-être déjà plus très loin du
moment où les écosystèmes ne seront plus
des puits de carbone mais n'importe quoi
entre à l'équilibré et des sources
vous avez un autre facteur inconnu celui
là de déstabilisation rapide du système
climatique qui pourrait intervenir qui
concerne ce qu'on appelle les hydrates
de méthane
je sais pas si vous avez vu ça les
hydrates de méthane si vous savez ce que
c'est qu'un hydrates de gaz non alors en
hydrates de gaz
c'est simple c'est un cristal mixte de
gaz donc vous avez les molécules d'eau
qui forment des petites cages qui
peuvent avoir des formes variées ça
dépend du gaz qui est emprisonné et le
centre de chaque cage vous allez
retrouver
une molécules du gaz considéré donc si
c'est des hydrates de méthane et bien
les molécules d'eau s'organise en
cristal pour emprisonner des molécules
de méthane mais vous pouvez avoir des
hydrates avec d'autres gaz à l'aise ça
ressemble à un cube de glace enfin je
veux dire ça ressemble vraiment la glace
sauf que ça peut brûler c'est assez
rigolo et ça n'est pas un assemblage
chimiques
c'est un assemblage physique c'est un
peu comme si vous construisez une cage
d'écureuil là vous savez pour les gamins
en emprisonnant au centre des bars eu
quelque chose qui pourrait pas s'en
échapper c'est un peu ça désiré de grâce
vous en avez qui se forment et en
particulier des hydrates de méthane là
que vous avez c'est comme dans la
cuisine à faut tous les ingrédients donc
il vous faut de nous ils vous font du
méthane et il vous faut d'autres
pressions pour rassembler tout ça ou
est-ce que vous allez trouver de l'eau
du méthane et de haute pression dans les
talus océanique où vous avez le plancton
qui sédimentent qui vous donne de la
deûle à des résidus biologique qui
peuvent être décomposés par des
bactéries qui génère du méthane parce
que là c'est une vie anaérobie dont vous
vous retrouvez avec du méthane de
l'autre vous êtes au fond de l'océan et
si vous êtes à quelques centaines de
mètres sous la surface de l'océan où
vous avez des pressions qui sont fortes
donc vous avez de la formation
d'hydrates de méthane dans le sédiments
océaniques et les autres endroits où
vous pouvez avoir ce genre de choses
c'est à quelques centaines de mètres
sous la surface des hautes latitudes
donc dans le grand nord canadien et dans
la cité et en sibérie où là c'est pareil
vous avez tous les ingrédients qui sont
nécessaires pour la création de ces
hydrates de méthane
si vous prenez un tout petit diagramme
thermodynamique
voilà à quoi ça ressemble vous pouvez
avoir ici des hydrates de méthane dans
la partie qui est colorée en jaune sur
sept clubs c'est à dire à partir de 300
m de profondeur si vous hâte à cette
température mieux la part zéro celsius
et puis au fur et à mesure que vous avez
une température de long qui s'élève
vous devez être de plus en plus profond
ça c'est pour la partie océaniques pour
voir apparaître les hydratants question
alors comme les hydrates ils peuvent pas
apparaître dans le libre il faut
obligatoirement qu'il soit inclus dans
le sédiment pour y rester ça veut dire
en clair que ils peuvent apparaître
le dans les sédiments océaniques en
fonction d'une profondeur qui dépend de
la température de l'eau à cet endroit là
et ça peut durer jusqu'à temps que le
gradient géothermique fasse remonter la
température
jusqu'au moment où on sort de la zone de
stabilité je vous préviens dire une
question d'un terreau banque vous pouvez
descendre en profondeur avec le gradient
géothermie qui vous augmente la
température une fois vous une fois que
vous avez franchi le plancher océanique
la température remonte quand vous vous
engouffrez enfoncé vers les entrailles
de la terre et à ce moment vous avez la
possibilité d'avoir des hydrates entre
le plancher océanique et le moment où la
courbe de température fait ressortir de
la zone de stabilité
en pratique vous pouvez donc avoir des
hydrates dans les premières centaines de
mètres des sédiments océaniques qui sont
sur les talus continentaux
la quantité totale d'hydrates de méthane
sur terre où est volontairement apprécié
sympa non de géologues
quand vous mettez leur vue côte-à-côte
considère qu' ils contiennent à peu près
80 carbone que l'ensemble des réserves
de charbon
ces hydrates de méthane ya un certain
nombre d'opérateurs pétroliers qui
aimerait bien pouvoir les exploiter
parce que le méthane c'est le gaz
naturel dont qui aimerait bien pouvoir
remonter ça des plancher océanique et en
faire du gaz pour alimenter les
cuisinières et les chaudières
alors ça pose un petit problème c'est
qu'en général ces hydrates ils sont
dissous à d'écrans où sont présents à
des concentrations de quelques pourcents
devancé dimanche solide
donc c'est un truc qui est pas facile à
exploiter avec un rendement énergétique
positif
et en plus ils ont la très mauvaise idée
quand voulait remonter des profondeurs
souvent de se désagréger
parce que si vous remontez dans un truc
pas hermétique
dès que vous sortez de la zone de
stabilité quand vous leur mettez du
sédiment craque
les molécules enfin le cristal je
dissocie
le métal se dissout dans l'eau ou fait
des petites bulles etc par contre en ce
qui concerne le climat
ça pourrait être un vrai problème les
deux zones où sont situés les hydrates
de méthane vont être concernés par le
réchauffement climatique
la première zone ici c'est l'océan
partir du moment où vous allez
réchauffer l'eau c'est en surface vous
avez créé une onde de chaleur qui va
descendre vers les profondeurs alors
cette ombre de chaleur elle va pas
descendre très vite et n'a pas être
extrêmement puissante au début mais si
elle venait à commencé à réchauffer un
peu l'eau qui est présente au niveau des
hydrates et bien vous fait sortir les
hydrates de leur zone de stabilité
ce que vous réchauffer un peu l'eau et à
ce moment les hydrates se désagrège et
alors c'est même pas facile de savoir ce
qu'il advient des hydrates dans ce genre
de cas parce que ça dépend de la taille
des bulles qui sont libérés au moment où
les hydrates se désagrège
une autre possibilité c'est que vous
ayez des glissements sous marin dans le
cadre du changement climatique ou
pallanca du changement climatique du
reste est à ce moment vous avez des
quantités d'hydrates significatif qui
peuvent être libérées dans l'eau est là
aussi en fonction de la taille des
bulles et la distance à laquelle vous
êtes de la surface ça vous fait une
irruption de méthane dans l'atmosphère
ou pas je vous rappelle que le méthane
est un gaz à effet de serre c'est pour
ça que c'est intéressant de se pencher
sur ce genre de choses
le deuxième compartiment vous avez du
méthane donc sous le sol gelé en
permanence des hautes latitudes là c'est
pareil si vous commencez à dégeler le
pergélisol et vous avez longue de
chaleur qui se propage dans les
profondeurs un moment ou un autre la
question est de savoir si vous allez pas
tomber sur un réservoir d'hydrates de
méthane et si ça va pas vous faire des
choses désagréables
tout ça c'est le point d'interrogation
peut-être qu'ils ont su peur pour rien
peut-être que là il ya là un risque
majeur c'est une strate if du fait que
encore une fois quand vous faites sortir
le système de ces conditions d'équilibré
qu'on a connus depuis dix mille ans à
grande vitesse vous vous rendez compte
au fur et à mesure qu'il ya des tas de
domaines dans lesquels peut-être qu'il
ya un coup vous n'avez pas vu venir qui
va nous tomber sur la figure je défile
ir en remettant en perspective les deux
problèmes dont je vous ai parlé jusqu'à
maintenant vous avez ici un ensemble de
coop que je vais bien évidemment vous
préciser qui sont décrites sur impactant
qui fait un siècle jusqu'à un millénaire
la courbe du bas puisqu'elle passe par
un maximum et qu'elle tend vers zéro
ensuite normalement vous aurez deviné
tout seul c'est les émissions de co2 de
l'humanité encore une fois elles sont
absolument condamné à passer par un
maximum et à décliner derrière y'a pas
d'autre choix et la quantité totale de
combustibles fossiles à la disposition
et la quantité totale de forêt à
défricher ça n'est rien d'autre que
l'intégrale de cette courbe puisque
c'est le cumul des émissions de co2
qu'on mettra dans l'atmosphère à cause
de l'inertie chimique du co2 du fait qu'
il faut diviser les émissions actuelles
par 2 avant de voir la stabilisation de
la quantité de co2 dans l'atmosphère
eh bien vous voyez que ce n'est pas le
moment de passe le maximum des émissions
de co2 que la quantité de co2 se
stabilise dans l'atmosphère il va
falloir attendre longtemps derrière pour
que la quantité de co2 se stabilise il
faut revenir à la moitié puis derrière
il faut perpétuellement baisser ses
émissions de co2 pour qu'on ait
simplement la stabilité de la
concentration atmosphérique et encore ce
diagramme qui a été établi en 2001 2
tient pas compte de l'inversion des puis
terrestre dont je vous ai parlé tout à
l'heure
donc en fait ça pourrait être encore
plus bas qu'il faudrait aller si ça
s'trouve le profil des missions qu'il
faudrait avoir pour que ça soit stable
c'est d'avoir un moment des émissions
négatives sert prenons seulement on
n'utilise plus un gramme de pétrole de
gaz et de charbon mais en plus on se
démerde pour avoir des processus par
exemple des plantes très résistante au
chaud et à la sécheresse par existant
qui permettent de retirer du co2 de
l'atmosphère
l'évolution de la température moyenne
est parti
pour être positive pendant des siècles
après qu'on ait passé le maximum des
émissions de co2 est là aussi
cette courbe ne tient pas compte d'une
rétroaction brutale qu'on pourrait avoir
parce que on a les écosystèmes qui
dépérissent parce que on a à la banquise
qui baisse beaucoup plus vite
ok 10000 étendu qui diminue beaucoup
plus vite que prévu parce que et c'est
parce que encore une fois le système
climatique et intrigue complexe et que
c'est très difficile d'avoir les idées
très claires très longtemps en avance
l'idée qu'il faut retenir de ça c'est
que vous voyez que c'est pas le moment
parce que maximum des émissions de co2
que on est entre guillemets payé de
retour en ce qui concerne les processus
qui ont été mis en août
en d'autres termes les processus qui ont
été mis en route sont des processus
extrêmement inerte extrêmement inerte et
vous n'avez pas la possibilité
simplement en faisant baisser les
émissions de co2 de renverser la vapeur
c'est pas possible c'est ce que je vous
ai montré la dernière fois là il ya de
toute façon at-elle d'un demi degré à 1
degré à l'échelle du siècle peut-être de
3 degrés à l'échelle de quelques siècles
auquel on peut difficilement échapper
aujourd'hui vous avez un talon de
quelques mètres d'élévation du niveau de
l'eau auquel on peut plus échapper
aujourd'hui donc ça va se produire en
cinq dix quinze siècles de toute façon
est toute la question aujourd'hui est de
faire en sorte que ce pic ait lieu le
plus tôt possible et le plus bas
possible pour éviter que l'ampleur des
conséquences ici ne soit considérée
comme trouve inacceptable parce qu'ils
en auront à assumer la charge et qui
seront pour une large partie ceux qui
n'auront pas profité de la fête qui se
sera passé là admettons que ce pic des
émissions de co2 soit involontaire
donc en d'autres termes les émissions de
co2 baissent parce que à grande échelle
parce que pour nous on sait pas grand
chose on à la répétition sur l'ensemble
gaz pétrole et charbon de ce qui est en
train de se passer aujourd'hui sur le
pétrole sol un
donc en gros c'est la contrainte
géologique qui force à ce qu'on ait des
émissions de co2 en baisse parce que la
quantité d'énergie fossile disponible
est en baisse
eh bien vous voyez que cette énergie
fossile qui a fait l'ensemble du 20e
siècle et qui est de très loin
l'énergie la plus facile à utiliser en
particulier le pétrole qui est de très
loin l'énergie la plus facile à utiliser
on se retrouve dans une situation a
priori pas très sympathique dans
laquelle dans le même temps que
l'énergie donc ce qui permet de faire
face à l'adversité à moindre coût baisse
vous avez une augmentation des problèmes
à gérer et une augmentation dont on me
verra que difficilement la fin comprenez
bien que d'être mis dans ce genre de
situation c'est pas le truc le plus
sympathique qui soit et on est c'est
typiquement le genre de situation qu'il
faut chercher à éviter toute la
difficulté encore une fois étant
d'anticiper sur un truc qu'on n'a jamais
vus et de s'obliger à faire des efforts
pour que ça n'arrive jamais je voulais
déjà dit mais je vous le redis c'est une
situation particulièrement difficile à
la fois pour la puissance publique mais
aussi pour les patrons des entreprises
qui vous embaucheront et la fin pour
vous même dans votre vie de tous les
jours puisque à votre âge imaginer ce
qui va se passer dans 40 ans et en tenir
compte demain matin est un exercice que
je c'est difficile
pour finir voici quelques enseignements
généraux qu'il faut que vous reteniez de
ce panorama
vous avez compris que bien qu'il soit
interdit de faire des probabilités avec
un événement unique parce que d'une
certaine manière ce que je vais faire en
parlant de risques
et bien pour l'essentiel des
conséquences qui vont vraiment nous
toucher ce qu'on va manger si on va être
malade pas malade
si on va avoir un travail ou pas un
travail si on va être plutôt en
démocratie ou plutôt en dictature etc
etc
il est totalement impossible je dis bien
totalement impossible d'avoir une vue
déterministe des choses c'est totalement
impossible et même pour les grands
paramètres d'évolution du système c'est
pas possible non plus puisque c'est le
premier rendre fonction de ce que les
gens vont faire dans les quelques
décennies qui viennent se surprend à
l'évidence
vous ne pouvez que born et des possibles
mais vous ne pouvez pas avoir de vue
déterministe personne n'est capable de
prédire avec exactitude ce que va faire
l'humanité dans les 30 ou 40 ans qui
viennent donc c'est un raisonnement même
si c'est pas le bon deux types alors
peut-être pas probabiliste mais
prudentielles c'est à dire où on paye la
prévention ou pas il est dommage comme
ça qu'il faut c'est comme ça qu'il faut
voir la chose qui s'applique
la deuxième chose à laquelle il faut
faire attention c'est que quand vous
parler d'avenir il est de bon ton
d'utiliser des conditionnels le futur
simple il faut de temps en temps s'en
méfier et il est bien évident qu'une
certaine il ya un certain nombre de
choses dont je vous ai parlé qui sont
possibles qui n'arriveront pas je
souhaite que ça n'arrive pas et là
encore parlé du futur avec des futurs
simple et bien c'est quelque chose que
dans les cas présent il vaut mieux
éviter cela étant il faut aussi éviter
le dire elle le symétrique d'une
certaine manière de ce réflexe qui est
de penser que dès lors qu'on sait pas en
russe que rien parce que ça c'est un
réflexe extrêmement répandu mais en
rendant extrêmement répandue je suis sûr
que vous avez tous vu au moins une fois
dans le journal quelqu'un a déclaré que
puisqu'on savait pas il était urgent
d'attendre d'eux s'est pas exactement
mon point de vue je pense qu'on en sait
bien assez justement pour comprendre que
le temps de la tente pour être sûr qu'on
sert vraiment de manière absolument
certaine
ben on va quand vous jeter du haut de la
tour eiffel vous pouvez toujours enfin
vous projetez du haut de la tour eiffel
en disant on va peut-être qu'il ya
quelqu'un qui est à ce moment là va
passer en bas avec un robin claque 3
mètres d'épaisseur et que etc
je suis pas sûr que ça va pas se passer
donc voilà c'est moi je vous conseille
pas tenter l'expérience
là c'est exactement pareil l'idée que le
temps est avec nous et donc on peut
attendre jusqu'au moment où on sort tout
ce qu'il faut pour agir est à mon avis
malheureusement une idée fausse et enfin
la dernière chose sur laquelle j'insiste
énormément c'est le fait que ce qu'on
sait faire aujourd'hui on ne sera pas
nécessairement le faire dans 50 ans il
ya des choses qu'on saura faire ne ou
qu'une fraction de la population sont
raffermis
parce que l'un d'eux processus qui est
très fortement à l'effet de cliquet
c'est l'accumulation des connaissances
ça c'est très clair par contre il ya un
processus qui est moins un effet de
cliquet parce que lui il est assez
largement fonction du régime politique
en place c'est le partage des
connaissances donc il ya une petite
fraction des gens qui peuvent savoir et
avoir accès à un capital de
connaissances ou de technologies qui
leur paraît très bien s'en sortir
ça ne vous garantit pas que tout le
monde ya accès donc la première chose
qu'il faut qu'il faut bien voir c'est
que certes les connaissances vont
augmenter mais la diffusion de ses
connaissances vous savez pas comment ça
va se comporter et par ailleurs il ya un
certain nombre d'autres événements qui
vont prendre place simultanément et en
particulier si comme cela est possible
l'augmentation du pouvoir d'achat des
deux derniers siècles à était l'exacte
traduction de la diminution du prix réel
de l'énergie dans le siècle qui vient ou
se pourrait fort bien que le prix réel
de l'énergie se mettent à augmenter
après avoir diminué
eh bien vous vous rendez bien compte que
la capacité de réaction à la disposition
de chaque individu va baisser et ce qui
n'est pas un problème aujourd'hui peut
devenir un problème majeur
même à climat a changé ou faiblement
modifié dernier exemple pour illustrer
cela la canicule de 2003 dont je vous ai
parlé
vous prenez un processus accrochant
parce que c'est même pas dit que c'était
aussi intense
il ya trois siècles ça faisait cinq cent
mille morts ça faisait cinq cent mille
morts parce qu'à l'époque vous aviez pas
d'adduction d'eau potable énergie vous
aviez pas les cadavres qui était
embarqué rapidement énergie
vous aviez pas le foin qui était
acheminée rapidement par camion là où le
bétail avait plus rien à manger
nrj vous aviez pas la climatisation pour
les gens qui se sentaient mal énergie
vous aviez pas les forces de l'ordre
pour venir rapidement là où il y avait
des problèmes et éviter que les gens se
tapent dessus
énergie etc etc donc ce qui fait la
différence
encore une fois entre un événement qui
ne va pas être un problème est un
événement qui va être un problème
ça peut être soit l'intensité de
l'événement soit l'attitude que nous
avons à y faire face
et encore une fois quand on raisonne à
des échelles de temps qu'ils sont de
plusieurs décennies ou du siècle certes
l'événement auquel on va faire face pas
changé mais le ton est peut-être plus
notre capacité de réaction face à
l'adversité va changer aussi
et vous ne pouvez pas raisonner à
capacité de réaction constante
là aussi c'est un processus qui est
malheureusement très courant dans la
cervelle d'un trop grand nombre de gens
et qu'ils aient eu la has une manière
extrêmement erronée de raisonner voilà
je vous libère et la prochaine fois on
parlera d'économie d'énergie